[Music]
how's it goin everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
relating to Marvel and the MCU today we
have Black Widow news yell I know it's
been super hard with everything going on
right now with the coronavirus movie
theaters for the most part around the
world have been temporarily shut down
production of movies for Marvel Studios
both at Disney and Sony have been
temporarily suspended and of course
movie release dates have been pushed
back the biggest one that we're most
excited for right now being Black Widow
now of course the big question about
Marvel Studios is Black Widow right now
is is it even going to get a theatrical
release there's been a lot of talk
recently that has been more along the
lines of speculation from some people
that are well known inside the community
stating that Disney is considering
releasing Black Widow on video on-demand
or possibly Disney Plus and this could
be good news or bad news depending on
your preference of how you'd like to see
the Black Widow film for the very first
time but fortunately for us today we
have two reports from people who have
spoken directly with Disney that can
confirm whether or not the Black Widow
movie is going to get a theatrical
release or whether or not it's going to
be on video on demand so I'll go over
both of these reports and explain the
decision if you're new be sure to
subscribe to stay up to date on
everything that is happening right now
with Marvel and the Marvel Cinematic
Universe I'll be doing constant updates
now the first report comes from Skyler
Schuler who runs the Dizz insider if you
couldn't tell by the name that is inside
her focuses on inside scoops and general
information about upcoming Disney movies
of which of course Marvel is included
Skyler and the dis insider are very
reputable and today he said spoke with
someone at Disney today and they let me
know as of today Artemis Fowl is still
slated for its May release but can
change and that Mulan and Black Widow
will be released theatrically just
sharing with you what I was told and
obviously things can change
now again Skyler has contacts at Disney
he runs the Dizz insider so somebody at
Disney told him that Black Widow is
going to be released in theaters the
other report comes from comic book movie
calm who reports news as well they have
also reached out to a contact that they
have at Disney and that person told them
the same
thing black widow is still being planned
for a theatrical release so this is how
it stands right now black widow is going
to be released in theaters though and it
will probably remain that way despite
whatever you may hear and here's why the
budget for Black Widow was 150 million
dollars the movie is expected to earn
one a billion dollars which is very
likely given that it's the first film of
phase four from Marvel Studios and fans
have been waiting for a black widow film
for over eleven years and not to mention
everyone's going to want to see the
movie after her death and Avengers
endgame and the fact of the matter is
Black Widow cannot earn a billion
dollars going to streaming or video on
demand not to mention the film industry
and the economy is in pretty bad shape
right now and releasing black widows and
theaters would definitely help it and
Marvel Studios and Disney need it as
well as they are losing literally
hundreds of thousands of dollars a day
their parks are closed and the
production on all of their movies are
halted right now so even though things
could get worse and perhaps Disney's
back-up plan would be to release them on
video on-demand or streaming unless
things get really bad they won't do that
they will stay true and release Black
Widow in theaters but I'm curious to
know what everybody thinks about this
would you rather have it release in
theaters or would you rather it go
straight to video on-demand and
streaming let me know what you would
prefer in the comments down below don't
forget to give this video a like and
subscribe and notifications turned on so
you can stay up to date on everything
that is happening right now with Marvel
and the MCU and when I hit 550 thousand
subscribers I'll be given away an xbox
one or a ps4 winner gets to choose for
live updates you can follow me on
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching willful